en un ambiente de profunda devoción el
Papa Francisco celebró este sábado la
tradicional misa de gallo en la Basílica
de San Pedro en el Vaticano Después de
tres años de pandemia las celebraciones
navideñas de este año se llevan a cabo
sin restricciones sanitarias durante su
homilía Francisco deploró El consumismo
y la mundanidad que rodean esta
celebración de Navidad muchas veces
marcada por la prisa voraz de poseer y
de consumir dijo Francisco frente a esto
invitó a los católicos en el mundo a
encontrar de nuevo el sentido de la
Navidad tomando como ejemplo la historia
del nacimiento de Jesús y el contexto de
extrema humildad de extrema pobreza en
el cual nació este niño en un pesebre el
pesebre del descarte y del rechazo dijo
Francisco Jesús nace pobre vivirá pobre
y morirá pobre para el papa esta imagen
del niño en el pesebre nos enseña que la
verdadera riqueza no está en las cosas
sino en las personas dijo Francisco se
trata de la décima Navidad del Papa
Francisco desde el inicio de su
pontificado una de las celebraciones más
significativas para los 1.200 millones
de Católicos en el mundo